naja ok geht einfach einfach hierhin
einfach hier offen so da kann kann uns
keiner die treppen oder so da hinkommen
die kommen
skills und an alle zuschauer von logan
herzlich willkommen zur sechsten folge
von minecraft legend mit und ihr seht
zwei von 32 minister moment dom von andy
hat sind uns nach geträumt nachdem er
die konfi geschrieben habe 18 uhr drei
bier xxxlutz 18.04 schreiben die x7
anymore
und ja die sind drauf geht drauf gehen
rauf kommt noch ich lade sie unseren
unseren unserem teil
denn wir machen eine wollten wir nicht
nur fünf minuten folge machen folgen hat
die folgen der plan leute wir machen
hier einst noch kurz das deinen stil
dass das spiel nicht bei dir gefunkt hat
weil wir hatten gerade ein fehler
ich mache jetzt mal dem logo mach mir
erstmal eisen zeuge ich gucke mich
derweil ganz schillig um hier mal stapel
grauen darauf ist darauf ist geschissen
hier mein game ist abgestürzt wieso
was ist jetzt so was habe ich irgendwie
items gedruckt jaja zwar etwas getrübt
wenn ich das jetzt irgendwas verpackt
ist mit unserem eisen alter leute wir
machen heute fünf minuten folge geben
machen uns noch kurz eisen rückfall
nochmal für logo und uns zwei
eisenstädter und dann locken wir uns
wieder aus und locken simpson wieder
hoch lockt uns dann wieder ein werden
können die auch gegen gegen die beiden
am besten gegen andy morne direkt mal so
hier zeigt nimmt das nimmt das alter des
tieres war ruhig berüchtigt beruhigt ich
brauche ein schwert das jetzt wichtigste
erwartet kürzlich hatte so was brauchst
du noch noch nächsten schwert alles
daran noch zwei dicke da ist ein stück
übrigens nicht nur zu abnorm sticks hat
man noch so zackig es nicht wert für
dich alles klar dann sind wir soweit das
ging ziemlich schnell wollen wir noch
als ich ab 20 level wir brauchen
unbedingt ein entspannter wir können
noch mal vielleicht kurz hast du noch
kohle
acht stück habe ich noch darum geht
einfach mal rein und brennen wir uns
noch mal kurz was ich den ganzen gold
alter leute gerne haben wir es auch oben
liegen lassen weil sie arbeit die
könnten die können unglücklich bei uns
ein pc rauscht richtig wir können
unmöglich bei uns wäre wenn du bei uns
haben so folgen geschaut und tom getötet
aber das haben sie natürlich nicht
gemacht weil die fähre spieler sind man
kann ja von heimspielen komme und ja wir
holen uns auf schnelles reisen und dann
wenn die spitzhacke mehr das ist ein
problem wollen wir uns auch hoch bauen
aber das hat richtig erkannt
richtig es kann aber wir können seb und
ich habe auch keine spitzhacke mehr hier
habe noch nichts fix wir können uns hier
auch wenn es jetzt richtig betrachten
was das was haben wir eigentlich so
großartig jetzt zu verlieren weiß ich
letztes mal haben wir auch die dik
tigers verloren also immer irgendwas
verlieren starb der grauen brauche ich
jetzt nicht den er wieder auf ich mache
mal 26 es hier
da kann man noch mal eine gedruckt und
ja leute vielleicht bauen ist jetzt hoch
vielleicht noch nicht haben noch nicht
entschieden wer das gold jetzt hier noch
brennen
ja mach mal ich kann ja schon mal
anfangen den weg hoch zu bauen
so sagen wollen wir die im partnertausch
nicht will die flauschige eule über aber
auch fackeln so wie man sich treffen im
café frage zeit wann schreibt das jetzt
nicht elitepartner nämlich nicht elitär
ja noch eine minute waren wir noch
wollen wir auch noch eine längere folge
machen ein bisschen hoch bauen
ich weiß nicht ganz ausgehen wenn wir
anderen sehen
danach müssen wir uns verstecken kann
einfach hast du noch cool also kannst du
noch fackel machen er ich hab noch 14
14h kann habe ich noch keinen run up
lenzen kannst du mal hoch bringen also
ja ich bin hin ich bin direkt hinter dir
ein bisschen wir brauchen damit es
nachher noch ein sehr wichtiges tor
machen können was sehr viel braucht
weniger trocken ja hier komm nimm dir
auch auf ok
wie hoch sind wir 29 es noch mal richtig
weil du ja fürs erste date ist das nicht
du etwas schrägen zeitalter ich war
heute extra fit mit extras und logischer
weise kann man logischerweise raton ja
logischerweise durch raton in deiner
welt geht alles ne meiner welt geht
alles logisch dass man mit indirect land
use
aber ich glaub ich weiß nicht was wir
lassen uns lieber wie wir bauen locken
und dann gleich aus okay weil die fünf
minuten dann nehme ich jetzt erreicht
jetzt genau ein bisschen können wir noch
halt halt du einfach auch ob du siehst
von denen man die können ja unmöglich
wissen wo wir uns weiter gebaut haben
das können wir einfach nicht wissen
wir wissen selbst nicht mehr die habe
ich bis heute wiedergefunden richtig
geordnet werden
aber das geld sind einfach mit einem
bruder zu traurig bin immer trauer der
folge immer noch nach wir hatten uns
aber jetzt schon junge kubanische level
wir haben werden
nächstens entscheiden können ich weiß
nicht wo die anderen sind auch die schon
entfernt haben also müsste morgen
thomson scho bei folge 7
und die habe ich jetzt einfach nach
geträumt heute also wir müssen richtig
aufpassen wir gerade richtig in gefahr
wir haben nachgeschaut und wollen uns
garantiert angreifen hundertprozentig
was hast du noch neben der höhe sind wir
ich habe noch ein bisschen mutig nicht
mehr viel war mir hier aufhören hast du
hast und hass und dings ein crafting
table ein holz habe ich noch ich habe
zwei holz
wir können uns keinen links anbrennen
kannst du schnell untergehen und kräfte
bauen
nee ich hab nicht mal genug holz seinen
qualitäten steht auf einer finca son
vida
wie soll ich denn in einem grafikengine
crafting table beförderte zu bauen oder
braten mitnehmen
ok werde ich jetzt noch machen darunter
ist klar wer kommt und mit seinem
hähnchen von hinten und wird mich würd
mich vergewaltigen okay wir sind ja auf
erde gestoßen
55 ich leg mich mal lieber wir können
jetzt fertigen stoßen sind als immer
wahrscheinlicher der oberfläche oder
leute bei 55 betten was man dir ich weiß
es nämlich nicht sieht man wie weit ganz
schön hoch gebaut haben ok bist du
hinter mir leute ich will dich an die
oberfläche die warten da die warten auf
uns die wollen aber wie machen wir
warten jetzt und wir werden in dieser
folge kanal vielleicht müssen wir gegen
sie kämpfen vielleicht nicht ich weiß es
nicht auf jeden fall wer auch immer dann
am ende überlebt hat ein problem weil es
keine rüstung gegensatz zu den anderen
teams hatten jetzt keine gelegenheit uns
noch irgendwie nachzuprüfen 77 30 wenn
ihr das b sind hier in einem natürlichen
höhlensystem da wo wir anfangs auch
waren kombi hoch folgt ja dann las er
von hier weiter hoch bauen immer schön
ausschau halten
aber ist es nicht mehr weiter weiß kann
ich nicht hat mir mal die koordinaten
von spawn aufschreiben können oder was
für geräusche euch sowieso ein komisches
minecraft gehört sowie also ja der
minecraft bedeutet nichts wir machen
rücken ein rockiges cable ist eine
schaufel okay bis an die oberfläche
wir sind an der oberfläche in genau dem
moment gehen oder spitzhacke kaputt so
ja ich an der oberfläche ich glaube hier
sind weißwein sondern eheleute wir
locken uns aus und gehen drauf wenn das
team drauf ist wir töten das bei mir
aber mindestens hier in die wand rhein
hatte
ja wo haben hier in die wand
ja ok wack reeber tarifkommission
einkommen in das loch gehen wir uns
alles klar
und einmal mehr davor macht es zur erde
ich habe erde leute und leute sehen uns
gleich wieder wenn ein team auf dem
server ist dann gibt es eigentlich schon
für euch richtig so leute sind wieder
und farbe und coop sind drauf und moore
und andy hat wahrscheinlich auch gleich
noch nach
rames wie man so schön sagt rahmen ist
und jetzt fanden wo auch essen
ich brauch essen habe ich völlig
vergessen interessen ich habe elf
karotten noch hier
er riskiert alles wirklich watte oder
oder wollen uns erst noch brennt mit ihm
haben wir haben keine iks gesetzt der
brennstoff verbrennt verbrennt beschützt
mich damit schützt mich der x6 ist drin
aber welches xxx fünf weiteren ex 71 76
ist es glaube ich ja okay dann komm komm
komm kosovo sind farbe und leuchten
orientierung verloren
hier hinter dir hallo in welche richtung
ist das porno diesen faktor seien unsinn
viele zombies portal weiter also nicht
jump nicht rampen ja nicht lampen nicht
haben und auf jeden fall alles töten auf
den ofen weg spinnen können auch
gebrochen für andere hast du jetzt die
seite aufgehoben
aber warte ich lieber mit komplett
verbrauchen wir ähnlich nicht jump man
mir gesagt ich soll mal fünf minuten
jemand
wir laufen jetzt hier einfach rum und
jagen die kleinen kojen söhne weißt du
weißt wo der sport ist bei welchen
koordinaten ich glaube wir im kern uns
davon
ja ich zumindestens
die orientierung verloren indes nach
vorne war die insel machte einfach mal
die minimap ein seminar an die iss an
dann suchen doch ganz nah an der macht
am markt große web anbieter wie macht
man das
26 minuten aufnehmen oder so weil wir am
anfang noch ein black screen gehabt
haben wo ich nichts mehr bis xx alles
klar und kann man auch raus zum auf
derlei pläne damit ganz klar da kommt
zwei mini baby zombies auf wie macht man
das mit 2 sz zoomen und herauszoomen du
musst ja ganz auf zoom ist er wieder
raus und mache ich was mache ich jetzt
auch mal so ich bin auf 0,5 und kann man
kann man auf der map of scrollen sie
sich bewegen weil ich sehe hier hin wie
nicht so viel da ist doch da ist das was
erleuchtet das was erhält dass du das
vorn sein oder das lesen wo ist was
erleichtern wollten wir folgen dir
siehst du mich in die richtung die das
licht an
das wird das wasser gegangen ja augen
auf china
na ja ich komme ja in die richtung das
licht auf der karte dann gehen wir dahin
da gehen wir dahin kommen
okay wenn man hier finden dem
irgendwelche scheiße machen wir das was
wir machen sie jagd auf farbe und basti
obwohl es die krassesten pvp am ganzen
projekt sind aber scheiß drauf
da hätten wir lieber gegen mister
montana art gmbh wobei man nicht weiß
was sie verkündet haben aber gesagt ich
kann nicht bei den anderen auch nicht
welche folgen die anderen x6 war das
glaube ich nicht
wir sind ungefähr alle gleich auf
hier ist nicht dass ihr das bei dieser
erhält gerade jetzt hier können wir
gebrauchen das war dieser erhält affleck
leuten hier ist hier ist holz verziert
er war jemand moment machen die müssen
irgendwo vom spanier aus sein
moment mal warum leuchtet es ist krass
das ist eine falle die man daraus egal
wie laufen weiter ja okay wir haben aber
noch ein wenig fußball man jetzt wieder
zeit gebaut wir gehen wirklich
richtungswahl minimap da waren ist das
wort hast du ihn nach vorne
okay okay dann sag ich folglich von
getötet
weiter das getreide wird das kann ich
gebrauchen weil wir hungern sonst ja
okay okay hier lang jemand erkennt zwar
kaum was aber hier müssen also alle
alles andere denn einfach an die monster
vor weihnachten die haben
ich muss kurz die monster slayer ok
alles klar alles okay okay
einfach rein in den sparten erstmal den
fraglichen oder guck mal guckt sich um
noch zuckerrohr zuckerrohr abbauen das
wechseln nur auf sand aber wächst
eigentlich auch bei wenn es in
meeresnähe ist auch auf gras mitten auf
seinem acker stehen bleiben ich komplett
ich wartete
wir müssen uns ganz ganz dicht zusammen
bleiben ganz dicht okay ganz lesen wir
bauen alles an heuer ab und ein kaputter
zu gebrauchen was wir finden ja alle
also alle potenziellen nahrung so wissen
ansporn leute wissen haben sie aber
erstmal was ist wenn ihr was in solchen
häusern hier sind gehst du ja okay waren
adecco kiste das ist hier so schön wie
kürbis sein kannst damit darf man darf
man holz aus der stadt abbauen wenn ich
mir jetzt noch mal von einem stimm
unternehmensantworten wo bist du ich bin
in seinem haus hier oben drin was kommt
da rauskommt daraus ich bin in der mitte
aus grafing ja in dem haus drin ja wo
man schnell verändert wir haben nicht
mal eben auch einfach ich kann ja auch
einfach ein fernes abbauen oder hier ja
und ich einfacher zum spawn ich bin hier
versuche wieder raus hosenboden sind
aber wo sind die jetzt wo sind die jetzt
leute die sache ist ab 19 uhr die kisten
sind noch gefüllt dokumente müssen vor
dem haus raus ich sag's dir heut geh ich
glaube ich glaube ich kann ich gar nicht
glauben ich kann aber er ist eben kein
räumen
ich glaube ich jetzt raus gekommen ein
kürbis zu verwerten
ja aber nur mit eiern und natürlich
schlecht das natürlich schlecht dann ich
warte hier der mitte ja ich baue gerade
noch ein fenster wenig aus okay okay
okay ich bin raus ich glaube aus pro
sind also sind die wo sind die wo sind
die folge es vorbei wir schauen uns auch
kurzum wartet da oben da oben ist
cockpit strings wo es noch eine
spitzhacke nähe doch hast du
stimmt doch gar nicht doch eine
spitzhacke habe ich ags das netzteil
achters war von außen zugänglicher ich
bin richtig schön war das papier ab
jetzt noch ein kuchen drin gebrauchen
sagt ja gut mit wegen kümmert sich
eigentlich nichts kostet nicht groß mit
anfang außer all fliegen sagt dass
jemand beim funken einer chance klar wir
müssen schluss machen soll jetzt hat
jetzt eine zweite op dass lotte wir sind
amds vorn und wir geben gas
wir geben gas und wir warten einfach auf
offene nicht auf die nicht gelegenheit
die sich bietet und dungeon wir wieder
nachkommen wir erholen uns doch mal wie
kann nichts machen ja ja okay geht
einfach einfach hierhin einfach hier
offen so da kann uns keiner die treppen
oder so dahin kommen die spenden kommen
dem onlineshop müssen beenden
als nächstes kam wissen ich bin solo
live ich kann nicht ich hab ich keine
kraft mehr hatte kreise kamen sie und in
dem moment in dem moment wo wir geändert
beenden wollten ihr comeback rennen dann
einfach weg und einfach haben wir uns
irgendwo verstecken uns dort kommen wenn
einfach kann ja ich kann ich kann nicht
ich kann mich kein skandal kombinieren
was machen wir wollen jetzt rein bleiben
was sie drauf gehen müssen uns hier
verstecken ganz okay okay du hast du
noch eine fackel
japan habe ich noch so jung ich bin ganz
so alt oder die vor alter sorge hat dass
wir konnten aber ihr habt gesehen ich
habe nicht korrekt und die haben uns
richtig schnell down und ich glaube das
ausloggen ausloggen ausloggen er okay
okay okay wir bleiben in kontakt um bis
zum leute sich böse plötzlich fanden
konnten aber wir sind jetzt auf jeden
fall hier oben und den nächsten wald den
gehen einfach drauf seid einfach krass
gesehen wir hatten keine chance gehabt
wie weit ich vielleicht war die doch zu
heftig vielleicht haben es übernommen
aber wir werden fighten und wir holen
uns einfach den nächsten schritt auf
bedürfen hat auch nicht an video von
auch nicht einfach blind drauf gehen und
sterben dass kann man auch nicht machen
das ja auch scheiße
aber wir sind bei der nächsten folge
drei macht's gut und show